je suis bien militaire économique
l'utilisation de ces missiles 10 watts
occidentaux soviétique c'est bien sûr le
stade ultime la catastrophe à laquelle
on ose à peine songé mais elle est là en
filigrane derrière toutes les décisions
prises par les états majors des deux
blocs
reste que pour en arriver là il faudrait
que de nombreux verrous et préalablement
sauter c'est le scénario que nous
propose maintenant patrick lecocq la
troisième guerre mondiale risque t-elle
l'éclatement
je crois que personne ce soir ne peut
répondre à une telle question mais en
revanche tous les experts sont d'accord
pour dire que la fin d'année 83 et
l'ensemble de l'année 84 seront parmi
les plus difficiles de ces dernières
décennies
alors comment pourrait éclater un
conflit je ne parle pas bien sûr d'un
conflit que les experts appellent
périphériques c'est à dire en afrique en
asie ou en extrême orient
je parle d'un conflit en europe comment
pourrait éclater une guerre
vous le savez de part et d'autre du
rideau de fer des centaines de milliers
d'hommes se font face des milliers de
mégatonnes pourrait un jour ou l'autre
peut être demain d'ailleurs déclenché le
feu nucléaire et l'apocalypse sur notre
univers est finalement en théorie tout
pourrait venir d'un simple enchaînement
de petits faits d'incidents
et puis d'affrontements alors ce soir
nous vous proposons un exemple imaginons
par exemple qu'un appareil américain
faisant la liaison entre francfort en
allemagne fédérale et berlin en
allemagne de l'est disparaissent tout
d'un coup des scop radars de contrôle
il disparaît alors qu'il survole la rda
univar war et anita bense y sont déjà
selon le quartier général de l' us air
force en europe
l'épave de l'appareil américain à ses
141 star lifteurs qui transportait 154
passagers a été repéré non loin de la
frontière de la république démocratique
allemande
selon certains responsables du pentagone
à washington l'appareil américain
disparu cette nuit a été abattu il n'y
aurait pas de survivants dans un
discours radio télévisé sur l'ensemble
des chaînes américaines le président des
états unis annonce que l'acte de guerre
commis contre un appareil désarmé ne
restera pas impuni selon certaines
sources les forces armées des pays
membres de l'alliance atlantique ont été
placées en état d' alerte dans une
dépêche de l'agencé tass les autorités
soviétiques évoque pour la première fois
le sort de l'appareil américain pour
moscou il s'agit d'une provocation
délibérée fomenté par les milieux
impérialistes occidentaux moscou annonce
que le peuple soviétique saura faire
face à cette nouvelle menace
washington demande la convocation
urgente du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies l'appareil américain a
battu la nuit dernière aurait été
atteinte un des missiles et sa cape
ganev alors qu'ils veulent est
légèrement en dehors des couleurs aérien
prévus pour les liaisons entre la rfa et
berlin l'avion américain abattu effectué
une mission d'espionnage affirme chef
d'état major de l'armée de r&d à l'armée
de l'air de la république d'allemagne
démocratique n'a fait que son devoir
un appareil militaire de reconnaissance
mig-25 soviétique a battu par la chasse
ouest allemande
une unité militaire est-allemande
franchissant la frontière entre les deux
allemagnes intercepté par les gardes
frontières de rfa
l'unité est allemande avait comme
objectif la récupération des caméras
2025 a battu par la luftwaffe
des combats sporadiques se poursuivaient
à la frontière entre les deux allemagnes
selon bonne l'artillerie est allemande
aurait ouvert le feu à plusieurs
reprises sur les troupes de la rfa le
quartier général de l'otan'' hamon
annonce que les troupes du pacte
atlantique commence à prendre leurs
positions de combat
trois divisions des forces armées
soviétiques en rda la 6e db2 lagarde
la 25ème division blindée et la 21e
division d'infanterie motorisée font
mouvement vers la frontière
le chef de l'état après s'être entretenu
par téléphone avec le président
américain
et avec les chefs de gouvernement
européens a rejoint le pc jupiter le
chef de l'état décidé de mettre en état
d' alerte maximum la force de dissuasion
française
en revanche les forces françaises
d'allemagne n'ont pas reçu l'ordre de se
porter vers la zone des combats combat
aérien entre f-15 et mig 23 flogger un
combat aérien oppose depuis plusieurs
minutes des appareils américains et
soviétiques selon le quartier général de
la dix septième air force des appareils
f 15 ha du 22e tactical fighter squadron
basée à pittsburgh ont été prises à
partie par des mig 23 appartenant à la
16eme armée aérienne tactique soviétique
de f 15 et 6023 auraient été abattus
pour la première fois depuis 1945 des
soldats américains soviétiques échangent
des coups de feu en centre europe la
flotte soviétique de la baltique aurait
débarqué des troupes dans le nord de
l'allemagne
la bataille fait rage à la frontière
entre les deux allemagnes plusieurs
régiments serait au contact les pertes
de parts et d'autres seraient
importantes
le poste de commandement volant de
l'armée américaine a décollé de la base
d'andrews les principaux responsables
américains seraient à son bord les
principaux dirigeants soviétiques
auraient quitté moscou pour rejoindre un
poste de commandement secret stop
arrêtons là ce scénario de cauchemar et
réveillons-nous tout ceci n'était que du
cinéma
ou plutôt pour ce soir de la télévision
mais si ce conflit avait réellement
commencé que se serait-il ensuite passé
nous avons je crois de solution à
proposer
la première est pessimiste c'est la
solution de l'apocalypse après un combat
classique et en application des
doctrines militaires des deux blocs
l'urss ayant fait usage massivement
d'armes chimiques l'ouest auraient
riposté en utilisant l'armé nucléaire
tactique de part et d'autre
la parole aurait donc été donnée ensuite
oss 20 et au pershing 2 le passage
alarme stratégique devenait inéluctable
c'était la fin sinon du monde du moins
de notre monde
l'autre solution est elle même un tout
petit peu plus optimistes la bataille
c'est en généraliser sur le front et
sans avantage précis de part et d'autre
les deux blocs se trouve ramenée
finalement à la case départ poussé
délibérément inoffensive amènerait en
effet l'adversaire à faire usage de ses
armes nucléaires et donc au couplage
nucléaires tactiques nucléaires
stratégiques
l'ange de la conquête vaudrait-il les
pertes qu'un tel conflit occasionnerait
poser la question c'est en réalité y
répondre resterait donc une solution
parler le dialogue par le téléphone
rouge le dialogue comme celui que nous
connaissons depuis 30 ans maintenant
voilà il ne faut pas oublier qu'en toile
de fond de ce dossier il ya toujours les
négociations qui se poursuivent à genève
ce sont elles qui doivent décider
officiellement en tout cas de l'avenir
des armements soviétique et amérique et
en europe